the Joe Rogan experience I think
Tarantino still pulls it off oh yeah
yeah no I mean he's a rare guys that
still you you watch a movie and go Jesus
Christ like the [ __ ] that he gets away
with that's a Tarantino movie like Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood that is a
Tarantino movie there's not like if you
told if I saw that movie and you said
who made that movie I'd be [ __ ]
Tarantino like that movie if they didn't
they're going to jail he gets away with
so much in his movies seem like his
movies and he's a family yeah he knows
movies really well yeah and no I mean
thank God for him you know I mean I
really enjoy his films and it's I met
Quentin I was at a film festival in CJIs
Spain it's a science fiction fantasy
film festival as a guest and I was there
that's where I met Peter Jackson we
actually he sat next to me in a
screening and we became friends and and
he had his movie brain dead have you
ever seen that
no oh it's really good gnarly fun it's
really gory but funny gory and really
clever
um about anyway see when did he make
that well this was like in the 90s or
something I guess I I'm real bad with
dates you know but anyways we were
sitting and talking and Freddy Francis
who was a director and a director of
photography for did a lot of Hammer
movies and and stuart freeborn was there
ever sitting in this thing and there was
this big kind of goofy kid walking
around you know and and I thought he was
just like a fan so I said come on over
and sit down with us didn't only started
talking and go what are you doing here
and you know he was obviously like an
American he goes I have a film here you
know and it was Reservoir Dogs and we
went to see it and I actually left in
the scene where they're torturing the
cop it's funny people think I like gory
gory stuff you know because I've done it
in films but real stuff and if it's
really intensely done on a film like
that was mmm I mean I thought he was
gonna let this guy light this guy and
fire if that muezzin where he's got the
cop in a chair at one point I said I
can't I don't want to see this so I left
and so did Wes Craven Wow yeah and we
went and he got so jazzed by that you
know Wes Craven couldn't take my movie
and Rick Baker couldn't take my movie
yourself
oh yeah that's awesome oh no it was and
that was a great thing I mean like I
said I asked was my introduction to
Peter Peter Jackson and we became fast
friends we kind of had the same
background it's like you what you said
to me about wanting to be makeup artist
and reading those things I know so many
people like that you know you know Danny
Elfman it was said that to me really
yeah
John Fogerty likes that yeah I don't
know they wanted to be makeup rights but
he really likes like that stuff you know
slash you know a lot of you a lot he's
different people and you know and they
went into rock and roll instead of that
you know
[Applause]